I go to an orgy with a bunch of girls
after a fight and one of the girls has
HIV and she walks into the gyms like hey
I have HIV it's like cool the
consequences of those bad decisions had
serious repercussions I do sometimes
wonder if there's such a thing as too
much responsibility well you take
responsibility for things that you don't
have responsibility for and it sounds
like maybe that Creeps in yeah there
might be a little creep so if you look
at all of the things that were going
wrong in my life almost all of them were
my doing like there are my choices and
the repercussions from those you know
like putting babies in a few different
women at the same time like nobody
else's penis in there like that's mine a
failure at work indecisiveness in school
like all of those things those are my
decisions you know my motorcycle that
was my it was me that crashed that you
know like I'm going down 90 miles an
hour on Highway 46 you know that's a me
Choice sure that had pulled out you know
like had I been going 55 I could have
been able to stop I definitely hear you
but I'm gonna go ahead and accept
ownership for the vast majority of the
problems in that specific time period